hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
development of a novel molecular msi
assay
with an expanded panel and automated msi
status calling i am christy joel of
labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo fisher
scientific for more information on our
sponsor please visit
thermofisher.com forward slash msi
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the
ask a question box and click send we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or you can report your problem by
clicking on the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational ms
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce today's
presenter dr charles
baudo dr baudo is a molecular biologist
in the genetic sciences division
clinical vertical at thermo fisher
scientific
and his development efforts are focused
on oncology applications
recently he was the lead developer on
the applied biosystems
truemark msi assay a new msi detection
kit
with an expanded marker set and
automated analysis
for a complete biography on dr baudo
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen welcome dr
baudo
you may now begin your presentation
thank you for that introduction christy
hello and thank you all for joining this
webinar today
my name is charles baudo and i'm an r d
scientist at thermo fisher scientific
in the genetic sciences division
clinical vertical
our job is to develop content across the
infectious disease and oncology space
and today i'll show you an oncology
application a fragment analysis test
to detect the presence of micro
satellite instability or msi in tumors
first i'm going to give you a background
on what msi is describe the dissection
method we've developed over the past two
years
and detail the performance of the kit on
clinical research samples
but first some background on
microsatellite instability
microsatellite instability is the change
in length
of small repeat units in the genome
in this diagram on the top we can see an
eight monomer go side repeat
example on the left side of this diagram
mismatch repair proteins identify
polymerase voltage
that happens during dna replication and
corrects the number of repeat units
we began with eight repeats and we ended
with eight repeats
and this is considered microsatellite
stable
however on the right in an example where
mismatch repair proteins are deficient
the replication error is not corrected
and the number of repeat units is
changed
from eight to four this is called
microsatellite instability
these changes can be detected by either
ihc
or by pcr
immunohemic immunohistochemistry
detections
detect for four to five different
mismatch proteins using monoclonal
antibodies
and they can have a high false negative
rate up to
around 10 percent because you can have
expressed
but non-functional mismatch repair
proteins
pcr and fragment analysis is the gold
standard method for detecting micro
satellite instability
because it can detect functional
failures of mismatch repair proteins
and it has a lower false negative rate
in 1977 the national cancer institute
held a meeting in bethesda maryland
to develop guidelines for msi testing by
ptr
for a hereditary form of colorectal
cancer known as
lynch syndrome that panel consisted of
mononucleotide and
dinucleotide repeats over the course of
the next seven years it was determined
those dinucleotide repeats were less
sensitive
and also highly apolomorphic so they
reconvened in 2004 to update the
guidelines
to include only mononucleotide repeats
in a small
five marker panel
in 2017 key truda an immunotherapy drug
was approved for
dmmr or msi high tumors regardless of
cancer indication
and since then msi testing has increased
rapidly
in this diagram here this is a
example of a fragment analysis
electrophorogram
showing a normal adjacent tissue of a
colorectal cancer research sample
on top and a tumor sample on the bottom
if you've never seen one of these
electroparagraphs before the x
axis is the amplicon size and the y-axis
is the peak height of the fluorescently
labeled
amplicons for bat 26 as an example
this first marker you can see the
wild type allele in the normal sample
and in the tumor sample
but you can also see a smaller amplicon
in the tumor sample
this is indicative of microsatellite
instability
and this profile here is very common
prototypical
of colorectal cancer samples
it's important to analyze microsatellite
instability in cancer research
and here are just two examples for lint
syndrome and immunotherapy research
in lint syndrome there's common related
cancers including colorectal cancer
gastric and endometrial
and some other related ones including
prostate ovarian and others
and roughly one in 400 people have lymph
syndrome
but most don't know it around 95 and
individuals with lync syndrome have a
higher lifetime risk of
having colorectal cancer around 80 and
end of neutral
60 it's relevant for immunotherapy
research because
deficient mismatch repair or msi hive
tumors are more sensitive to
immunotherapy
than micro satellite stable tumors and
so patients with msi high
respond better on these particular
therapies
this slide here shows the mechanism of
accent action
in the immunotherapy target so on the
top panel here we have a tumor cell with
frame shift
mutations that is mismatch repair
deficient
and it's important to know that not only
are these mutations occurring at micro
satellites in these small repeat
regions but all across the genome and so
what can happen is
other proteins become have frame shift
mutations and are displayed on
the cell surface of the tumor and can be
recognized by the t cell
however pdl1 and pd1 interaction between
the tumor and the t-cell
can prevent clearance of the tumor
with immunotherapy drugs like ketrota
that can bind to pd1
preventing that interaction between pdl1
and pd1 allows the recognition of the t
cell and the neoantigen that's formed
through this mismatch repair deficiency
on the left we have a kaplan-meier curve
showing the overall survival of
patients with mismatch repair
deficiencies or might
or microsatellite stable tumors
in the presence are at in the presence
of a pd-1 blockade
and you can see that patients with
microcepha that have microsatellite
instability
do better than patients that have stable
microsatellites
on the right is the incidence of
microsatellite instability across
various cancer types and the top three
cancer types that have the most
incidents are colon stomach and
endometrial
and those are the cancer types that we
focused our development effort to
developing a
pcr-based msi protection kit
which i will begin to talk about right
now
our we developed a kit that does not
require
a normal control for colorectal and
gastric samples
and we also paired it with automated
software
calling that takes the results from your
fragment analysis runs and will
automatically interpret those
and tell you if you have micro satellite
instability in the specimen or not
in the original guidelines there were
five recommended markers
for msi detection by pcr and we've added
we've developed a panel with 13 msi
markers plus
two sample identification markers which
allow you to determine if
samples have contamination or have been
mixed up
the kit only uses as little as two
nanograms of ffp derived dna
and from that dna you can get results to
report in less than four hours
four hours the kit is compatible on our
sig studio and 3500
series genetic analyzers and it comes
with at no additional cost
the software that automatically will
analyze the results
and export reports
this is the workflow for our kit so
it begins with a 15 minute pcr sample
preparation
and then a two-hour fluorescent pcr
reaction that occurs on a thermocycler
afterwards those fluorescently labeled
amplicons
are combined with high die and a size
standard
and then run on our fragment analysis
capillary electrophoresis instruments
either the sig studio
or 3500 after those files
come off of the instrument you can
import them into our software
and get results in less than five
minutes
this is information on what the markers
are
on our panel there are eight markers
that are publicly known msi markers are
historically been used in lynch syndrome
or colorectal screening
and five markers that are proprietary to
applied biosystems
and these were selected for being
quasi-monomorphic
which is important for tumor-only
analysis
and also for high sensitivity across
multiple different cancer types
the two different sample identification
markers that we use are penta d
and th01 these are a penta and
tetranucleotide repeat
respectively
here's an example of a colorectal cancer
research sample
with a tumor and normal match on the
left
side of this figure is the tumor profile
and on the right side
is the normal profile each row
represents a different channel
beginning with fam which is blue vic
med taz and sid
in each channel there are various
different markers the first one for
example has
three different micro satellite msi
markers
in total there's 13 msi markers in the
two
human identifications here you can see
very clear and interpretable signals
and instability is shown at all of the
msi markers
when you compare the hid markers
for example in the red channel second to
last from the bottom
you can see that the profile between the
tumor and the normal is identical
and the same between the two hid markers
in the green channel
on the far left this indicates that
these two samples are paired from the
same individual and there's no simple
contamination
ran our kit and performed analytical
validation on
greater than 150 research samples which
include colorectal gastric
and endometrial
so i'm going to show you a case study of
a sample provided to us by aurp
that's a colorectal cancer research
sample which can explain
how important or how useful the
automatic caloric calling algorithm we
have in our software
can really be so i'll only be showing
you examples from
two of the three microsatellites in the
fam channel
and it's an example of an obvious micro
satellite instability
or a really subtle example
so once again towards you towards these
electroparagrams
the x-axis is the amplicon side and the
y-axis is p-chi
the normal sample is in blue and the
tumor sample
is in green in both the normal and tumor
sample you have a larger wild type
allele
present at around 80 base pairs but then
in the tumor sample you see a second
stutter cluster that's about eight base
pairs separated
between the main peak and the normal and
the main peak in the
mutant sample this is
the canonical example of microsatellite
instability in a colorectal sample
that's
extremely obvious however there are
cases where it's not very obvious
for example in this same sample for the
marker nr21
we have a one base pair separation
between the claw type and mutant
main note peak there are examples where
the phenotypes range anywhere between
these two examples
or even more difficult to detect
especially in
endometrial cancer types and so this is
where
an automatic coloring algorithm can
really be useful
to help identifying these edge cases
we also developed synthetic contracts
that can help
reveal small deletion detection
complexities
so in this example we have a 20
variant allele frequency in each of
these electroparagrams
and we have different base pair
deletions starting with five base pairs
all the way down
to one in the top left we have a five
base pair deletion synthetic construct
at twenty percent vas
and the deletion is readily evident
however as you decrease the deletion
size it becomes
more difficult to detect the micro
satellite instability
so we fed the data from all of our
research samples
from colon gastric and endometrial and
these synthetic contracts
not just at 20 percent baf but
um several other ladder of the afs
into an algorithm to help us predict and
and automatically call microsatellite
instability
so the next two slides are going to show
the performance of the automatic calling
algorithm
in the tumor and normal example
and just a tumor-only example so there's
two different algorithms in the software
first this is the tumor normal analysis
so
we've tuned our algorithm to maximize
sensitivity and specificity
on both the 3500 and seek studio genetic
analyzers
and if you haven't looked at one of
these figures before this is a receiver
operating characteristic curve
and on the x-axis you have the false
positive rate and on the y-axis you have
the true positive rate
this allows us to pick a setting that
helps us maximize the accuracy
of the calling and from here we can see
that the algorithm uh
improve is very good with an aut of 0.94
in all of our samples but it increases
in accuracy
when you compare only larger and larger
samples with larger and larger deletion
sizes and there's comparable performance
between
both of the platforms
calling auto automatically in samples
without
a normal comparator is really difficult
because you don't have a sample from
that same specimen to help make that
comparison
however we created an algorithm with a
large database of normal samples
that have stable micro satellites to
help do that prediction anyways
and so where this algorithm really
shines is in colon and gastric
samples where those deletions that
deletion phenotype is
often quite large with an average around
seven base pairs it's not recommended to
run endometrial
research samples without a normal tissue
because they can have
deletions as far down as one base pair
and can be really difficult to detect
so on this uh figure here you can see
the sensitivity
of the tumor only algorithm in both the
3500 and the six studio
instrument platforms and it increases as
you increase
the deletion size up to
a high sensitivity
we also benchmarked our assay against
ihc
and we did this comparison with 162
different research samples across three
different tumor types
we had 84 different endometrial samples
34 colorectal and 44 gastric
and the ihc was done on all of these
samples and they were staining for
either
at for all four of these different
mismatched repair proteins
it was considered deficient mismatch
repair if any one of those proteins had
a deficiency
and all in all the samples we also ran
are true mark msi
assay our essay found that we had high
coordinates
of around ninety percent accuracy
between the prpcr basic
test and ihc and
of the discoordinate sample sixty
percent of them were endometrial samples
which are known to have lower ihc
coordinates
and are difficult to assess for
microsatellite instability because they
have really small
deletions and it's important to know
that
greater than 50 of our sample test here
in the software endometrial sample so
we're doing really well
in a really difficult sample type
anyways
we also took the main competitor product
and compared it against ihd
and uh found that the accuracy of the
promega system
was lower than the accuracy of our true
mark assay
90 versus 83 percent for the promega
assay
per mega had 17 no calls where
and the true mark msi assay made a call
on 14 of those 17 samples
the reason why the promenade system had
a lower bit
accuracy is because they only use five
markers
and it doesn't perform as well in
difficult cases like analyzing
endometrial samples
although there are difficult cases
within colorectal and gastric as well
so the additional markers on the true
mark msi assay allowed us to pick up
smaller instabilities
more frequently
the next part of the talk is going to
focus on the software solution that we
have
and to show you the interface of the
software
and the various different ways that you
can interact with it
so the software is designed to
exclusively be used with our assay
and it allows you to have automatic
calling of markers
you don't need a tumor normal match
except for endometrial samples there are
very
for straightforward qc indicators and
review steps
and a simple review of specimens and
batches workflow
you can select which markers you want to
include in your analysis
and you can make manual calls when
needed if you don't agree with the
algorithm
you can also respo report export results
quickly in multiple format types select
pdf
cvs and vcf and it's included at no
additional
charge you can download it from this
link here
dive into what it actually looks like
this is an example of
after you import a batch of samples in
on the left you have your batch view so
here i have multiple different patches
and i've selected one batch
and in the batch view it gives you some
quick information like the number of
different specimens that you have in a
batch
or if you've exported or if you've
completed your reporting
on the right is the specimen summary
view for that batch
and in this particular batch i have five
specimens within it
and that specimen view it gives you an
overall call it let you know if there's
any review flags
and it lets you know if the if you ran a
normal with your sample if they match
so there's an hid calling algorithm as
well that will automatically tell you if
you have sample contamination or not
this is if we click into one of those
particular samples
so if we click into for example the
bottom one
this is the specimen tab and you
get your typical true ferrogram view
where on the top left you can switch
between the different
dies and view the different markers that
are in each channel
and on the right you have a summary of
each of those different markers
the call the automatic call if there's a
review that the user should look at
whether or not you want to include it in
the in the report or
if you'd like to overwrite a call so in
this particular example the algorithm
called the marker api 17 has stable
when just from a cursory glance it looks
unstable
so here you can mark it as unstable
let's zoom in to that marker on this
next slide
you can overlay the tumor and normal
sample
and go marker by marker to confirm
your call so this is a really efficient
way to look at
the comparison between your tumor or
normal and indeed you can see the
smaller
stutter cluster in the tumor sample so
it does look to be truly
unstable this particular view is
especially useful
in sample text with subtle deletions
like endometrial
you can switch between specimens at the
top right
and stay on the marker you're looking at
or you can look at the peak
details there's a peak details tab to
see the peak heights
or make comments here as well
these are two examples of the reports
that we have
on the left is the specimen report where
in the report you have a summary of
which markers were unstable or unstable
and how many
any comments you made and a electro
fairground view of each of those
different markers
along with any other metadata
information that was extracted out from
the one on the right is the batch
summary view which gives you a high
level
view of all of the samples that were
included in that batch
the overall call the number of markers
that were unstable or stable
and other relevant information
so in summary the truemark msisa
achieved robust identification of
microsatellite instability
with using only two nanograms of input
and we developed a software solution
that can interpret those
electroferograms and those results very
quickly for the user and
export reports fast
this is a easy to use msi detection
system
and it can also be used with tumor only
samples in colorectal and gastric
cutting down the
casa sample in half for those sample
types
if you'd like to learn more about micro
satellite instability testing and our
assay you can go to thermofisher.com
msi and at this time
i will take any questions if you have
any
thank you for your time
thank you dr baudo for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar now to our audience
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for it
okay let's get started we have some
great questions already coming in
dr baudo other than ffpe
samples can blood sample be used for
germline detection
so we developed the assay for and tested
on ffp
samples although we do not do have
customers that are using it
and trying it on liquid biopsy samples
and the results are quite good
we plan to put an app note and a poster
out in the distant future showing the
performance in blood samples but i don't
have a time frame for that
right now thank you
now our next question
how do you identify msi low in this
assay
and what is the importance for the
patient
so um in the software the
the default is four or more markers are
called
as if they are called unstable that is
considered msi high
that's roughly 40 percent 30 to 40
percent of markers
to be called unstable is considered msi
high
as the default but you can change that
if you would like to modify that
threshold
that means between one two three one to
three markers if those are called
msi are unstable then they'll be
considered
thank you now our next question
oh go ahead
now dr baudo what are the new markers
and how did you choose them for this
panel
i'm sorry could you repeat that question
my audio cutout
yes no problem what are the new markers
and how did you choose them
for this panel
great question yeah eight of the markers
have been historically used
in detection of colorectal cancer and we
added five proprietary markers
and we selected those because they were
shown to be quasi-monomorphic
which means they have the same allele
across multiple ethnic populations
and that's important when analyzing
without a normal comparison
these five markers were also selected
because they showed high sensitivity
across
multiple cancer types and because
they're just the right size
around 20 base pairs too large and of a
homopolymer and you start to see more
natural variation in homo polymer size
than normal samples
which challenges msi interpretation and
too small
and it's hard to see the instability
dr gouda our next question we use your
gene mapper software already
can we use that for this assay too
you absolutely can use gmapper but we
created the new software specifically
for this assay
and gmapper doesn't allow automated
calling and reporting so
if you would like those features you
would need to use the new software
which is free to download
and which instruments can be used
so we performed analytical validation
on the 3500 family so that's 3500 3500
xl and the seek studio although we do
have customer
partners that are running the essay on
other instruments and it seems like they
have good results too
like the 3730.
dr battle how does the software work how
does it make automatic calls
without paired tumor and normal samples
the algorithm examines patterns in the
stutter clusters between
the normal and the tumor samples and
tries to determine instability there and
for tumor on
only out tumor-only analysis it's a
little bit different right because you
don't have a normal comparator
and so we have a large database of
samples known to be stable
that the algorithm can compare to
vado this next question is two parts did
you
validate only on colon gastric and
endometrial cancer
and how many cases what about other
cancers such as
pancreatic gbm
yes so we only performed analytical
validation on those three cancers you
mentioned
gastric colon and endometrial
although we have run our assay on many
other cancer types including pancreatic
and although i didn't show any of that
data here
thank you the next question why do you
recommend
running a paired normal for endometrial
tissue are there other cancer types that
need a normal match also
yeah that's a really good question so we
developed
our assay with the aim of not requiring
a paranormal tissue
and the sensitivity is comparable to
running balls to normal and a matched
tumor
in colorectal cancer and gastric
research samples but we do recommend
running a normal match for endometrial
samples because
msi is notoriously difficult to detect
in the sample type
due to very small often around one to
two base pair changes
i'm not aware of additional cancer types
that show the endometrial phenotype but
i'm also not sure that the research has
been done in
low msi high frequency cancers since
it's hard
to acquire a large enough msi cases to
do that studying
i think it'd make for a great research
project though
thank you now we do have time for more
questions but i do want to remind our
audience
that any questions we're unable to
answer live today
and additionally those questions that
are submitted during the on-demand
period
they will be addressed by dr gaudo via
the email address you provided
at the time of registration okay let's
continue
does your assay work with other msi
assays also
i think that question is does your essay
work with other
does your software work with other msi
assays and
um no the software will only work with
the
truemark msi assay
our next question is there any data
available for breast cancer
um i can look at what
first capable breast cancer samples
we've run and
um follow up with the individual who
asks that
question um in general um
it is known about msi msi frequency and
breast cancer
thank you the next question
does truemark msi analysis software have
any peak normalization
during automated calling
yes there is normalization because any
uncorrected large
amplification differences between the
tumor and normal samples could trip up
the algorithm so
we account for that
what is the sensitivity and specificity
of tumor-only analysis
compared to tumor normal analysis in
colon
and gastric cancers
yeah i think between the
two algorithms the tumor normal and
tumor only in those two cancer types
is pretty comparable although you are
going to see decreased sensitivity
in the tumor and only analysis
but only by a few percentage points
because on
average the deletion sizes in those two
cancer types
are often really large like seven base
pairs so you should still see really
high sensitivity for those
and dr bauto what is the sensitivity and
specificity of this assay across
different cancers
so the results i show today are for
endometrial cancer
gastric and colon i don't have
those types of statistics in
other cancer types available um and we
haven't
we don't have um hundreds of uh
examples of other cases um
where i could show powerful statistics
for that at this time although we have
run it in those
cancers and have seen instability
and called it correctly with our
software
dr gatto is the truemark software
compatible with a
3130 excel instrument
or would manual analysis using gene
mapper be required
i think you can try importing it into
the software
i don't promise if it'll work or not i
actually am
talking with a customer who's running it
on 31 30
next week uh so i'm interested in those
results myself
um but i think it's i don't see any
reasons why it shouldn't work
but i i'm not promising anything because
i haven't seen that data yet
dr batter what are the maximum peak
heights for all markers
allowed before the software cannot make
confident calls
on msi
so um you'll see when in the software
when
p-cuts are too high there'll be a purple
bar very similar to
gene mapper that says that the signal is
saturated
it'll still try and make a call but
there's going to be a warning
signal in there that'll let you know
that the user should review that call or
not
and typically that signal saturates
around 30
000 rpu or a little bit higher than that
and you'll see that saturation
by uh it causes pull up into other
channels and so
that's readily available ready readily
apparent
we tried spacing out the markers on the
panel such that if there's pull up in
any individual one of them
it will pull up into the what's
considered the msi region of another
marker
so it shouldn't confuse the analysis
now follow up to that question if that
happens does the software tell you
to repeat at a lower sample input
the software does not tell you although
your you can reinject the sample at a
lower injection time so the default
injection times in the user manual
i think it's 15 seconds you can decrease
that
if you want to re-inject it to bring
those signals
within spec but the software doesn't
tell you that
you have to do that or not
have you compared this test parallel
with bethesda panel
pantoplex panel and ihc with four
markers
yeah we showed some of that data today
um
so some of those markers
we definitely compared it to ihd with
the four um
proteins there and um the smaller number
of markers some of which are the
potential markers on the
um mega panel
let me show you comparable since
accurate and we showed
sorry we could we showed comparable
sensitivity and uh
specificity hd and better accuracy
relative to the per mega system
thank you and dr battle for adi 3500
with eight capillaries sometimes two
capillaries may not
work with same efficiency can this
situation cause false positive results
such as identifying non-existing small
deletions
um if you would like to
share any data you have on that i'd be
more than happy
to look into it i don't know that
specific
use that specific failure mode um
and how it relate to performance in our
essay
um i haven't seen that when i was
running
our our assay on the 3508 cap so
um if you have a system that has that
failure mode and
i'd be interested in seeing that those
results but i can't comment on right now
because i haven't
thank you and dr battle we have time for
one more question what is considered
msi high is it more than two markers
that show unstable
the default in our software is four or
more markers
are considered if they're unstable that
is considered msi high
but if you validate in your own lab a
different
threshold you can configure that in the
software
so you can change it to three or you can
change it to five you can also configure
which markers you actually want to
include in the report
so if you only wanted to include in the
markers you know about
um like say the eight
of 13 that have historically been used
in msi detection then you can only
include
those in your report as well so it's
configurable
thank you again for your time today dr
bauto now i do want to thank our
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
those questions we're unable to answer
live today
and additionally those that come in
during the on-demand period they will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided
at the time of registration i would like
to once again
thank dr charles doudou for his time
today and his important research
we'd also like to thank labyrinth and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
today's webcast can be viewed on demand
and lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now we
thank you for joining us
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day